nous en ce moment une chanteuse report
de tous les soirs très grand succès
cette chanteuse ses critiques christine
celle vous l'avez reconnue est pour vous
la présenter pour nous la présenter jean
ferrat puisqu'il est son mari depuis un
certain nombre d'années
alors jean ferrat présentez-nous votre
femme est une tâche de razz agréable et
très délicate à la fois parce que
j'estime je voulais ma femme je laime
beaucoup je l'aimais tout court et puis
je laime aussi en tant que chanteuse en
tant qu'interprète parce que je trouve
que certaines chansons qu'elle chante
j'ai jamais entendue chanter aussi bien
mais jean ferrat vous ne pensez pas
avoir gêné un petit peu la carrière de
christine je vis versa d'ailleurs la
question sera posée à christine tout à
l'heure je ne vois pas de quelle façon
j'aurais pu la gêne et christine vous ne
pensez pas que votre mari et gêner votre
carrière
moi j y ai un
et très heureux parce que
c'était un peu ma faute au débat et
ensuite c'est c'la foot 2
des gens qui se sont habitués à me
considérer comme madame ferrat et qui
ont fait très peu attention
personnalité artistique on espère pour
kaunas et madame fait rarissime
voilà c'est à dire quand on a commencé
tous les deux on était au même point
vraiment et moi j'ai continué en faisant
enfin je me rappelle à cette époque et
mon mari se rappelle certainement tous
les ans se disait on a fait un petit pas
et moi j'en ai j'en suis toujours au
fait type ah oui non enfin je ne sais me
santi pas finalement vous ont conduit à
bobino alors tous mais oui oui mais je
sais pas quand à dire qu'au début je ne
voulais pas je ne voulais pas j'étais
très orgueilleuse je ne voulais pas je
disais toujours que je me refusais de
faire ma carrière dire et par mon mari
dit - christine quand on voit votre tour
de chant à bobino c'est un tour de chant
à la fois sensible plein d'humour et
puis avec
par certains côtés étrangers ce que cela
correspond à votre personnage est ce que
c'est vous je t'attends je sais pas ce
que vous voulez dire par étrange que je
me trouve pas du tout écran je me
retrouve prêtres avec normand
jean ferrat pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
écrit de chansons pour qui ou très peu
n'a pas lu par pour gérer il en a écrit
une 12ème au moins oui nous connaissons
s'appelle tu es venu oui c'est une bien
jolie chanson que nous allons écouter
en ce temps-là gère
de clocher en clocher janvier les
pigeons qu'ils savent être nicher
auprès du verre
je mens le remet dans l'est
mais vingt ans
cherche je me sais quoi et quand la nuit
venait
de mon ombre et l'avant
super
tu
m
moi tout devient possible
le